have you heard of Lex Friedman Lex
Friedman
prayer and I think it's time to go pray
the Quran which I know less well in a
tweet he tweeted I hate that every
awesome thing comes to an end I say this
word because I can't find a better
descriptive word but but Muslims will
not accept this you will live forever or
you can have anything you want Elon Musk
now Jews will say and I being a Jew will
say this that that's because Muhammad
heard those stories from Jews Lex
Friedman you know hold on to this and
anyone else listening this is
historically documented last fun I must
have said to mankind he couldn't read or
write we invite you Lex Rabbi and
everybody else and this is uh give us
throwing some Love Your Way Elon Musk
something created the universe or the
universe is you know here how did it
come to be Elon Musk too when I get to
Mars man we'll get you past Mars we'll
get to Jannah
[Applause]
let me into my face
be upon him this is our religion Islam
Islam this is
show
[Music]
um
excellent good to be ready once again
with you good to have you on the program
have you heard of Lex Friedman Lex
Friedman
never heard of him never heard of him
[Music]
all right have you heard of Joe Rogan I
have yeah he's a UFC guy he used to be
an announcer or something yeah so much
Friedman he's a
[Music]
all right so you can see we're getting
to work and we need your support so go
ahead and help us to get this where it's
top notch inshallah
[Music]
Russian American Computer scientist
podcaster and an artificial intelligence
researcher and he also has good
relations with a lot of the different
other well-known podcasters out there
such as Joe Rogan's good friend of his
and recently he also had an Imam he
opened up his channel to have an Imam on
his on his program and that was uh I
thought that was a nice thing on his end
so I wanted to kind of return to him
the the location you know an invitation
also for him to hopefully get him on the
program
he had someone a rabbi on his program so
I got to see this and this is a common
misconception and you're an expert in
this area of misconceptions you know
inviting people you've you've also
you're somebody who studied Islam for a
long time you have a master's degree
in uh Hadith is this correct and other
Sciences of of Islam so I thought you'd
be the perfect fit to go ahead and to
address this issue so we'll get right
into this all right because this can
leave
a person thinking that well you know
this is just another religion Islam is
just like you know rest of them have
your choice pick one and as long as
you're a good person right so let's uh
jump right into this and uh get your
reaction how would you answer this the
Quran which I know less well I have read
it but I know it less well than I know
the New Testament and certainly less
well obviously than I know the Hebrew
Bible
um
is a very is in some ways a
parts of it are I I don't say this word
I say this word because I can't find a
better descriptive word but but Muslims
will not accept this okay is it take off
on the Torah in some things that is it's
the same stories as the Torah but
they're different now Jews will say and
I being a Jew will say this that that's
because Muhammad heard those stories
from Jews and also heard midrashim which
are rabbinic interpretations of those
stories and he wrote those down Muslims
will say no the Jews got it wrong and
Muhammad came along to correct the
record and tell the real story but
they're all telling the story of the
same they Hebrew the Hebrew Bible part
the abrahamic part they all tell the
story of the same characters but tell
them the obviously Christians accept the
Hebrew Bible as sacred scripture
um the Muslims
retell many of the stories in the Bible
uh what is what is common to all of them
is that all of them
are monotheistic faiths now in
Christianity that's more complicated
because of the Trinity but as
Christianity has developed over time it
clearly presents itself and thinks of
itself and is a monotheistic Faith as
well so you heard the points and a lot
of times these are kind of the same
things that are we hear this all I hear
it all the time so how what would you uh
so first thing I appreciate the rabbi
David will uh making it clear that he
doesn't know the Quran well because
obviously he doesn't from the statement
that he made
um and he seemed like he's being
respectful he just didn't know that
that's why I started this an
appreciation of him mentioning that
secondly I would like to point out uh a
very clear misconception that I hope
that the rabbi if he sees this video or
if somebody can share it with him uh
will understand is that for his
statement that Muhammad
heard these stories and wrote them down
would require him to be able to write
and according to the consensus of the
historians the prophet Muhammad peace
and blessings be upon Him couldn't read
or write solid Point Lex Friedman you
know hold on to this and anyone else
listening this is historically
documented the problem is fun I must
have said to mankind he couldn't read or
write so for him to have taken Jewish
scriptures and heard the stories and
written them would be impossible that
dismantles it just couldn't be secondly
um if somebody was to say somebody like
no no
who was uh and he's somebody who
practiced more Christianity and I knew
the abrahamic faith was the one that
told him about this let's stop right
there what's the name you're saying
who was a relative scholar who was a
scholar and he he was somebody who had
studied the Christian religion whatever
is out there at that time he had he had
so but he was not Jewish and Makkah the
city of Makkah where the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon Him didn't have a
president of Jews we don't know of any
Jews that lived in Mecca so for the
prophet Muhammad peace and blessing upon
him to have heard this he would have had
to go on outside there were Jews that
lived in Medina and there were three
major tribes and
the third one I forgot but these were
there in Medina they were not in Makkah
warakada novel was a relative of the
wife of the Prophet peace and blessings
be upon him and that was
but again he passed away in the very few
days of the Revelation the early time
when the Revelation began to be given to
the prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
he passed away
most of the Quran is not talking about
the people of the past I mean if you
look at the story of Abraham and Moses
that's a good chunk of the Quran but
that's not most of it there is a big
aspect of the Quran that discusses
events that are going on meaning when
the Battle of Badr was going on when the
Battle of was going on there are verses
about those so those couldn't be
plagiarized or copied from older texts
that doesn't make sense that's not the
way we could bring it together right
even the stories of the prophets of the
past as mentioned in the Quran are
uniquely different from them in the in
the Hebrew scriptures before I get into
that let's take it back a step for the
respected Rabbi what I would like to
point out and our viewers Muslim and
none
the earliest scriptures that you have
for the Old Testament the Torah being
the first five books of the Hebrew Bible
are going to be What's called the Dead
Sea Scrolls the Dead Sea Scrolls are
dated to be around 200 BC before the
time of Jesus peace and blessings be
upon him that means you don't have any
scriptures anywhere close to the time of
Moses or David peace and blessings be
upon both of them we believe in them as
prophets we respect them okay so
as Jews you don't have your Original
Scriptures you have stories that were
told and and retold and from that you've
collected some writings but these cannot
be preserved to the original writings
that would have been with Moses and
David peace and blessings be upon them
first off so this is not an original
right
secondly the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him did not study Judaism he did
not study any historian we would love to
challenge this Rabbi to find us a single
historian
who can bring any contemporary evidence
of the Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessing be upon him having studied any
other Faith he couldn't read or write he
was not a disciple of any religious
tradition meaning he believed in one
Allah he believed there was one Creator
he followed the way of Abraham that is
true but he didn't study Hebrew he
didn't know Hebrew he didn't know Greek
he could not have studied those
scriptures he didn't have Jews around
him in Makkah to have been telling him
these these stories and scriptures so
all of that is out the door that's just
a misconception
now let's go past that there are things
in the Quran and for those that are not
zealous of any religion please pay
attention to this and and think for
yourself
if you look at David
the prophet David who's called a prophet
even in the New Testament right and no
doubt he's from the prophets and kings
of the Old Testament right you look at
his story
how it was misconstrued in the Hebrew
Bible and how lies crept into it that
was then corrected by the Quran and just
as a human being I don't want you to
even respond from an Islamic just from a
human being let me ask you this question
and I'm asking this question to
everybody watching as well
if there is a pastor of your church or a
rabbi in your synagogue or an Imam in
your Masjid and he sleeps with one of
your
people from your congregation's wife
while she's married and he's out to war
defending the nation he sleeps with her
and gets her pregnant and then has her
husband assassinated and killed
would you would you follow such a
pasture or Rabbi or Imam who's a
adulterer fornicator who sleeps with
some a married woman and then kills her
husband would you
would you follow somebody I know okay
okay according to the Hebrew Bible David
peace and blessings and we as Muslims
don't say this I'm glad to find this
David King David was a prophet who we
love who we love and according to the
Bible even the New Testament calls him a
prophet okay meaning the people who
ordered to follow him he was the king he
was God's chosen he even in the Psalms
of David God says today I have begotten
you I mean to the love and is chosen him
right so so the people have to follow
him
according to the Old Testament the
Hebrew Bible he
peeps over to this woman taking a bath
which again we would never ascribe that
to a prophet sees her becomes lustful of
her
gets her in his Palace
has intercourse whether it's by force or
not I'm not sure but he has intercourse
repeated and gets her pregnant
and then find out that her husband is in
his army out at war with job defending
their lands he's one of the generals
he's one of the soldiers he's a soldier
in the army then he has him called back
and sends a letter with him
telling job to put him in the front line
so he gets killed wow so his wife who
David's been having an affair with
pregnancy
you see how could you ascribe this to a
prophet and this is not a disrespect to
the rabbi or like a you know trying to
undermine somebody or this is just
something that's just tell me this would
you follow a prophet like that
would you be comfortable with your wife
and children there and you're out with
somebody like that would God put
somebody in Authority that you had to
follow have you ever asked the rabbi or
have you asked anybody how do they
respond to this we have videos you can
see on the one message Foundation
Channel when we've discussed this and
you know many times the answer we get is
well God chooses Sinners and this and
that but again if you are
Force you're told that you had this is
your Prophet this is your leader this is
your king this is the one you have to
follow how would God put somebody like
that in Authority it's just back to the
argument that this is just proof that
the Bible that we have today has been
changed this is true exactly what you're
saying that we as Muslims believe and We
Know by for a fact that the Original
Scriptures of the old Hebrew Bible are
no longer with us and when those
scriptures were Rewritten from memory
from stories from from tradition from
different scriptures these things were
corrupted and added and that's why the
same Creator who inspired Moses and
Abraham and David inspired the prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
a man who could not read or write a man
who had no idea about the scriptures of
the Jews and Christians with this divine
revelation to correct that which was
corrupted so why didn't he copy that
also exactly good point why didn't he
copy if this was to become the story
then those mistakes those Stakes those
character assassinations that were done
against those proper assassinations
would have been copied and now what does
Islam say about the prophet about David
for instance he tells us that David
peace and blessings be upon him was a
righteous Prophet a prophet who led
according to what he was revealed he was
a king and a prophet we do not believe
that he raped or impregnated married
women or had their husbands committed
adultery lot
as mentioned in Arabic lot as we find in
the Bible who in the New Testament is
called a righteous servant and according
to many if you look at the the Old
Testament would be considered as one of
the prophets now whether you take him as
a prophet or not according to Christian
or Jewish Doctrine I'm not even get into
but he is called a righteous servant
right
we and Islam do believe he was a prophet
as well we have the story of story of
lot now you who are watching just think
about this a righteous man a man who's a
prophet who's to be followed who has
divine revelation
how would you view that person
in the Bible in the in the Old Testament
in the Hebrew Bible you will find lot
getting drunk not just getting drunk a
little bit but getting drunk with his
daughters his own daughters we're
talking about incest here and sleeping
with them impregnating them
again it was his daughters according to
the Old Testament the Hebrew Bible that
got him drunk but he got so drunk that
he slept with not just one but both of
his young daughters impregnating them
how do you this is very sensitive for a
lot of people hearing this some people
hearing this for the first time well and
they've had a shift and the hate goes
towards you now because you're bringing
it up I mean I I hope that those people
instead of hate they will open their
minds with love will open their hearts
with with wanting to understand and they
can go look up the verses themselves go
put in your Google search lot daughter
sex Bible the verses will come up you
can read it in your Bible at home if you
have a Hebrew Bible if you have a Greek
New Testament you can look at the the
statements about lot being a righteous
servant in in the New Testament you can
find the Hebrew Bible you can find about
him having repeated sex in a state of
being drunk with his daughters now you
just tell me yeah so what's the point
now the person says why are you bringing
this up I'm bringing this up because we
as Muslims don't believe that if the
prophet Muhammad was copying from their
scriptures he would have copied that too
but instead we know from the Quran and
the correct Story the character and the
rabbi alluded to that he knows that we
as Muslims know that Allah revealed the
Quran to correct that which people wrote
with their own hands and ascribed to god
wow this is powerful this is very part
so this is directly now responding to
what the rabbi is saying that Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessing be upon him
he talked about historically he can read
or write the person who was a scholar
you reference at that time also now
this these you you brought him up as
evidence now we're getting into these
stories that are there character
assassinations this is not also in Islam
in the Quran I don't care what religion
you follow just as a human being tell me
this if a man gets drunk enough to sleep
with his own daughter's incest and
impregnates them is that a righteous
person to you
would you consider that to be a morally
correct person would you follow such a
person
so even legally in America or in the
United Kingdom or in Europe or anywhere
else in the world if a person gets drunk
does that excuse them of their actions
no if you get drunk and you drive and
you hit somebody can you say hey I'm
sorry I was drunk if you get drunk in
the west today and you have incest with
your own daughters would you not be
arrested for it
so as Islam we didn't copy this we
corrected this by showing that this was
a fabrication against a righteous man a
prophet of Allah and we know in Islam
that this never happened
we know that
had daughters and he was a righteous
father to them he didn't molest them he
didn't sleep with them he didn't get
drunk with them we know that the people
were tested with the with the angels
that came and the people of lot tried to
attack them and loot and his daughters
and everybody from Sunni except his wife
they went with those angels they were
saved right so the Quran corrects these
mistakes now just a very important point
an idea I want to really emphasize on
this much of what you find in the Hebrew
Bible or even some of what you find in
the New Testament and what you find in
the Quran is in common for example if
you look at the Ten Commandments the
idea of there being no God but one I
mean there being none worthy of worship
except one God hero Israel your lord is
one don't worship idols don't steal and
things like this yes and I'll tell you
why because the same Allah the same God
the same Creator the same entity that
revealed that message to Moses revealed
that message to David revealed that
message to Jesus revealed that message
to Muhammad peace and blessings be upon
him so the difference is what you have
is when you don't have the original
scriptures for the Hebrew Bible when you
don't have any manuscripts of the Greek
uh New Testament dating back to the time
of Jesus and you do have
the preserved original language Arabic
Quran from the time of the Prophet peace
and my blessings be upon him that means
those things that people added and
misrepresented the Quran correcting wow
this is amazing let's go ahead and
invite our Brethren Humanity Lex
freedmen he
in a tweet he tweeted I hate that every
awesome thing comes to an end I wish it
could last forever
he's you're in the soul is yearning yes
what I mean he's uh getting to hear the
message he heard it from the Imam on his
program he actually went and followed
the Imam in prayer Imam he was following
him in prayer and I think it's time to
go pray
and it seems like now he's hearing you
know from the rabbi he's hearing from
other people of other religions but I
think anyone who's he's inquisitive now
right he wants to know and now you're
clearing up this misconception so
hopefully this can make the road easier
for him to come to the truth what would
you say to this and and that yearning
that the human beings to live forever
you know and we only know that you can
only live forever in Paradise right so
we want good for this uh this person Lex
Friedman uh what advice would you have
for him and how well
um I have some advice for him and for
the rabbi as well
um for Lex Friedman
um we'd like to invite you to Eddie and
the dean show
um come on down come on we'd love to
have a conversation uh you know again
and that's something wonderful is just
to talk just talk we appreciate the fact
that you brought a Muslim on your show
and you're open to having that dialogue
and want to invite you to the show so
you can have a dialogue with our brother
Eddie and if you want to invite us to
your show we'll be more than willing to
come and speak to you on your show we
don't really care about the views and
all that we care about communication
Building Bridges understanding and so we
want to invite you
um for the rabbi I would encourage you
to First learn about the Quran about the
preservation of the Quran about the
prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him and his background and how he
was not somebody who studied any of the
Traditions from the Jewish faith or the
Christian faith why he was somebody that
believed in one God yes he was
the religion of monotheism but he was
not somebody who could even read or
write to have collected those stories
from anywhere else and I want you to
learn that there were times when the
people who followed the Jewish faith
during in Medina they sent question to
the prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
knowing that he would not know those
answers unless he was an actual prophet
and one of those questions is why why
was Moses in Egypt when the bin Israel
the children of Israel are from Levant
from the area was called sham and this
is a question that Prophet didn't know
the answer to and Allah revealed from
the Quran Surat Yusuf and giving an
answer about the story of Joseph and how
the people in Israel ended up in Egypt
right and the Jews of that time they
said he could not have known that unless
he was a prophet we want you to learn
about the signs of prophethood that many
of the Jews of Medina saw
on the prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him and accepted Islam
became Muslims
and I want to give you some good news a
video is going to be released soon on
the one message Foundation channel of a
man who studied Christianity from the
age of 13 he was a Christian Street
Evangelical preacher he studied the
Bible he studied Hebrew he studied
Christianity in depth
to a point where he became a Bible
expert
and then he studied the Hebrew Bible
that this Rabbi speaks about and he
became fluent in Hebrew and he went to
Israel not Allah free Philistine and he
went and studied with the rabbis there
and then he continued that journey to
learn about the Quran
and he ended up inshallah you will see
the video accepting Islam you have this
video we have this video we'll be
posting soon on the one message
Foundation before we conclude now just
back to waraka benofa what did you class
what did you classify him was he was he
classified as a Christian
what was he
was somebody who studied the Christian
faith but he believed in Christianity
the way the original followers of Jesus
did so he was a true monotheist
monotheist yes would we call him a
Christian we would say he's from the
true followers of Jesus true followers
of Jesus so here's my point that now for
the true followers of Jesus you have an
example of
who said at that time whatever was
authentic whatever he had he confirmed
he said if I was paraphrasing if I was
young if I would be around he knew his
death was coming I would support he's
telling Prophet I would be with you yes
you are a messenger your people first
thing when the Quran started to be
revealed to the prophet Muhammad peace
and blessings be upon him in the first
verses that were revealed when he went
and told
warakam Norful told him that the one who
has visited you is Gabriel is jibril and
he does not come except to a prophet
Allah and he told him you're a true
Prophet this has been study this is the
scholar of the time the Christian of the
time the true
that if I live to a time when your
people will will push you out of your
city then I wish I could support you but
he died early on
but he even gave him this titling said
having studied the scripture I know the
people will turn against you and that's
what happened just because just because
of the message he's bringing a pure
monotheism but because he died very
early on he wasn't involved in the Hijra
or the migration or what the verses that
were revealed he never heard about later
but he did accept that the prophet
Muhammad is the messenger and that's why
it's considered one of the companions
one of the sahab amazing now you also
have a chief Rabbi was a scholar yes of
Judaism who's also living turn of time
Prophet Muhammad he ends up accepting
Islam so the heads right of knowledge
the academics of that time many in
Medina Abdullah Bin salaam you have
ahbar and others those that were Jewish
scholars in Medina now again I want to
clarify not in Makkah where the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon Him grew up but
in Madina when the prophetam went to
Medina he met them and many of them did
accept Islam and you had people like
Salman Authority Salman the Persian who
was a Persian man who used to worship
the fire and then he went and he learned
Christianity he learned Judaism he
learned Hebrew and Greek and he studied
and he spent time with the with the
scholars of those religions and from
what they told him he saw the signs of
prophethood on the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him and he ended up as a
Muslim and we hope that this Rabbi will
continue his search for knowledge and
the truth it will end up being a Muslim
as well I mean we hope I know in the
video he mentioned he doesn't know the
Quran well we hope that he studies it
better and he studies it in depth and he
sees how it corrects that which the
people had this
the disinformation that was spread
earlier this is so important because Lex
Friedman the rabbi others they'll hear
this and just nonchalantly this will
come up and a lot of people repeat the
same things and they discredit Islam
altogether and now they just leave it
off and they go on with life but then
now they hear the misconception
addressed and the facts academically
explain this and now you can be right
back to investigating Islam because
there's a lot of these misconceptions
and I want to make a point especially
for those watching
Muslims stick to the true message that
the prophets brought all of them all of
them the prophets had one message that
were called the one message Foundation
one message what was the message believe
in your creator worship none but that
Creator follow the prophet of your time
if I was there in the time of Moses I
would follow Moses peace and blessings
be upon him if I was in the time of
Jesus I would follow Jesus peace and
blessings be upon him but we are now in
the time of the Prophet Muhammad peace
and blessings be upon him and everybody
whether you're Jewish or Christian or
atheist if you want that salvation you
have to accept the last messenger the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him and
his message if you wanted like Lex
Freeman was tweeting live forever yes
because his life will end it will you
are going to have to submit not to your
desires or any hodgepodge that people
man-made religions and mixing this mix
and that is to the way that the Creator
sent and that's in Islam and then you
have Paradise forever
will Mount Every Soul shall taste death
that means this life will end for sure
I mean every single soul will taste
death
but Allah also tells us about the
Everlasting Paradise that you will be
khalidine if he had you will forever
there'll be existing in it forever
forever forever so we invite everybody
likes the rabbi everybody else watching
to have that Eternal Bliss a
never-ending life with no worries no
depression no bills no taxes no sickness
a life where you will be with your
relatives all of those that are in
Jannah and you will live forever and you
won't even be bored of things
not like not not like uh Elon Musk in
the same tread you know it's interesting
uh that I mentioned he said that to this
Elon Musk two two of the work because
he's excluding the Hereafter he said the
two worst things two worst possible
curses is you will live forever or you
can have anything you want Elon Musk in
this worldly life we get sick of things
yeah
and and this is
life that is a mercy from Allah yeah
because you don't want to get overly
attached to this world so if you love
some ice cream
you have enough of it you get sick of it
you love a particular movie you watch it
enough times you'll get sick of it but
that's because this life wasn't meant
forever and that's why everything in
this life has a decline the most
handsome man who started to wither away
and be old and disfigured by a certain
time if you live that long yeah the most
beautiful woman will sooner or later
lose that worldly Beauty but when you
enter the life of the Hereafter that's a
life forever
so your beauty never Fades you'll never
become less handsome you only become
more handsome a woman only becomes more
beautiful you only taste things to be
even better every time you try it and
that feeling of getting sick of
something is taken away from you like
jealousy like hatred like all those
things are taken away that is a
beautiful life an everlasting life a
life that is the true life a life that
we know is what we were truly created
for this is only a temporary Abode so
whether it's Elon Musk or the rabbi or
Lex we want to invite you to the
everlasting life and we hope the viewers
will share this video with those people
to get this message to them beautiful
beautiful thank you so much you know
people want to go into the Prophecies of
the Quran the preservations of the Quran
the Miracles of the Quran and this is
not a blind submission everything is
there lucidly clear that you can come to
a realization if you're sincere
your open-minded humble-hearted and the
formula that we always say what asks the
Creator alone for guidance Guide Me
Guide Me Guide Me that's it we tell
everybody you know who comes to our
table as well you know if they don't
accept Islam right they would tell them
look
tonight go home and everybody watching
when there's nobody there not for show
not in church not just turn to your one
Creator not to a prophet not to a monkey
or not to a cow to the one Creator and
say oh the one who created me guide me
to the truth and if you're sincere Allah
will guide you to Islam that's easy we
see it day in and day out that's very
simple easy to understand and I'll give
easy to do another homework point
a lot of what we see in Judaism today is
not from Moses or David or any of the
prophets peace and blessing be upon them
if you look at the the Orthodox Jews in
their dress code this comes from Europe
if you look at the furry hacks that they
have you know I asked a rabbi in in in
in quotes in Jerusalem where did you get
that this big fur looking hat where did
this from Moses from David where did you
get this like we as Muslims were the
Communists represent something close
with the prophet Muhammad War we we
prayed the way the prophet Muhammad
peace and blessings upon Him prayed we
we stick to that true message we look
more like Jesus than most Christians
today we look and act more like Moses
than most Jews today but a lot of what
we find in Judaism today has been
invented in Europe and exported into
Philistine and things like this the the
big top hats and the big coats where did
you get this from it's not what Moses
wore that's not what David wore peace
and blessings be upon them that's not
what they did taking a live chicken and
taking over your head for forgiveness as
a practice you find in some form of
Judaism today where did they get this
from now you can look it up YouTube it
they take a live chicken and you know
kind of take it over their head and the
chicken is you know you're holding by
the wing that's screaming and
it's not in the Torah it's not in the
Hebrew Bible you just made these things
up a lot of these practices have all
been made up and we're mostly made up in
Europe
this furry hat comes from Austria where
a king
was mocking the Jews and made them wear
foxtails to make fun of them and they
decided let's just own it and started
wearing it wow but it's got nothing to
do with the religion
these are all things that were invented
into the religion we want you to relieve
all that man-made nonsense and turn to
Islam the religion that's based on
divine revelation
look at the shirt you have that talks
about how you pray the Salah every
aspect of that we can prove from the
Quran or sahihadi from the Quran itself
or authentic narrations from the prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
our celebrations
how we can prove this unlike what you
find in eastern Christmas all these made
up man-made Pagan things right so we
want people not to be fooled by their
rabbis or by the synagogue or by the
churches and their priests and their uh
the pope or whoever else into these
Fabrications that have been brought in
the name of God and to turn back to the
original message the message of David
and Moses and Jesus and Muhammad peace
and blessings be upon them the message
of that one Creator to worship none but
that one Creator we find even in the
Hebrew Bible the prophets putting their
head on the ground and praying we find
that in the New Testament in the even
with all the corruption some of that
truth is still there where Jesus put his
head on the ground and prayed to the
father right that's how we Muslims pray
when is the last time you went into a
synagogue and saw people praying by
putting their head on the ground when is
the last time we went to a church and
you saw a Christian putting their head
on the ground like Jesus and praying
you don't find it we stick to that true
message and we invite you to that true
message we invite you Lex Rabbi and
everybody else and this is uh give Stone
some Love Your Way Elon Musk Elon Musk
too when I get to Mars man we'll get you
past Mars we'll get you Jannah
thank you very much thank you it's a
pleasure
and you if you would like a free copy of
the Quran
visit thedishow.com I'll get you one
recharge until next time assalamualaikum
peace be with you and uh I think it's
time to go pray
acquired the property and we're getting
right to work and with your duas and
support we can go ahead and get the
Masjid and megadawa Center up open and
running in sha Allah imagine every
person that prays here gets educated and
guided to Islam here you'll get a part
of all those blessings and rewards insha
Allah what are you waiting for brothers
and sisters you're going to leave it all
behind anyway so go ahead and invest in
your Hereafter that's Everlasting click
the link below donate right now may God
Almighty Allah reward all of you
foreign
[Music]